Ever since I was a young kid,
my grandpa tried to instill it in me
that the coal company is not your friend,
that they're going to exploit you.
They're going to squeeze
every bit of value
out of you that they can,
and they're going to leave you broken.
All you need to do
is look at this bottle of water
that I brought with me today.
Congressman Carter, I
talked about orange water.
None of us would drink this.
They told the people,
"Don't let your kids play in it
and don't let your animals drink from it."
From Pennsylvania and Ohio
all the way down to Alabama,
there are roughly 600,000 acres
of mines left to be reclaimed.
And as they sit, they
create more pollution
and have more erosion
issues and other problems
because they're not being maintained.
The death toll in Kentucky
continues to rise following
what the governor called
"The worst flooding
disaster he has ever seen."
There's a federal law
that, if you mine coal,
you have to clean up the
land when you're done.
And a lot of companies have found ways
to avoid doing that.
Bankruptcy seems to provide coal companies
a way to shed a lot of liability.
Hey, look, there's a stigma associated
with filing for Chapter 11,
'cause people confuse it
with you're going out of business.
We're not going out of business,
we're going to restructure.
This is a story about
how big coal companies
avoid their responsibility
to clean up their old mines.
My name is Junior Walk. I'm 32 years old.
I work for Coal River Mountain Watch.
Essentially what I do is go out
and document coal mining operations,
usually with video by drone.
Trying to find things
that the coal companies are doing
that goes against
environmental regulations,
like making roads in places
they're not supposed to,
blasting in places
timbering where they're not supposed to,
and get them in trouble on that.
So, welcome, this is the Coal
River Mountain Watch office.
When I was a kid, it
was like a pizza place,
but we've been here since like 2014.
Our main mission is to be a thorn
in the side of the coal industry.
We are going to keep on them
until they're out of here.
There was a bridge owned by a coal company
that had collapsed into the river,
and I called it in and
they made them clean it up.
This is the Brushy Fork Impoundment.
It holds back 7.8 billion
gallons of coal slurry.
It's a lake of toxic waste.
The Appalachian Mountains are beautiful.
I mean, being up in the mountains,
it's bright, bright green trees
and almost vertical mountains
rising away from the road.
At the same time, the
presence of coal there
is almost overwhelming.
I mean, it's really everywhere.
There are coal conveyors,
basically big pipes with conveyor belts
that run over the road.
So you're just driving along,
and then there's just a lot of big tubes
running over the road.
There's coal trucks
that are really, really
loud and really big
that go by, it seems like
almost like once a minute.
Some of the small towns we stopped in,
there was coal littering
the side of the road
because so many coal trucks go by
that coal shakes off the top of them,
and there was just little
pieces of coal along the road.
A lot of people we talked to
did feel like, we live
in such a beautiful place
and it's really been severely damaged
by the coal companies.
People talked about growing
up with family members
gathering ginseng or gathering firewood
or hunting in the woods,
and that, now, some of those areas
are just gray moonscapes
where they can't do any of those things.
This is the Twilight complex,
which is Lexington Coal Company operation.
It's a massive mountaintop removal site
that is a chunk of Raleigh
County and Boone County.
Initially, it was a
Massey Energy operation,
and then it sold to Alpha.
Then I suppose Alpha has offloaded it
onto some company known as Lexington
because they don't want to bother
with the reclamation
responsibilities up there.
This is the site that
Lexington is supposed to be,
you know, reclaiming, and they're not.
There's no equipment out on that site.
No work being done whatsoever.
I mean, it essentially hasn't been touched
since Alpha had it.
I first got interested in this story
when I was a bankruptcy reporter.
Coal companies went through a big string
of bankruptcies around 2015, 2016,
and during that time, they offloaded
or shed a lot of labor obligations,
promises that they'd made to pay workers.
And those were mostly picked
up by the federal government.
So I kind of had it in my head that,
you know, coal companies
and their obligations
was an interesting area.
Bankruptcy seems to provide coal companies
a way to shed a lot of liability
and come out the other side
as a profitable company
that still holds mines.
When coal companies go bankrupt,
any other legal actions
against them are often stopped.
So if we find a water pollution issue
and it's with a coal company
that is in bankruptcy,
there's often little we can do
for citizen enforcement
of water pollution issues
against a coal company
that's in bankruptcy.
We became focused on a
company called Alpha Met,
Alpha Metallurgical Resources,
because it's a really big company,
it's one of the biggest
coal companies in the U.S.,
because it's shed a really
large number of permits.
And a mine permit is what a company has
that allows them to mine coal
on a specific piece of land.
And attached to the permit
is also the responsibility
to clean up the land.
The story with Alpha
is they were doing
really well for a while.
They were buying other coal companies,
they were mining a lot of coal,
they were making a lot of money.
But around 2015, low natural
gas prices undercut coal,
and that helped push companies like Alpha
and other coal companies into bankruptcy.
Pretty soon after the bankruptcy,
Alpha passed on its used up mines,
or mines that had less coal
in them, to smaller companies.
And along with those
mines went the obligation
to clean up the land.
So, over the past decade or so,
really since about 2015
when several companies,
large companies went bankrupt,
we've seen a phenomenon
of companies shedding their liabilities.
Essentially, they will
sell their good mines
that still have coal to mine
to companies that want those mines,
and then they will sell their other mines
that often only need reclamation
and may have a lot of liability
to other coal companies
who agree to take them on,
usually because the original companies
are paying them to do so.
And we've seen several
rounds of that happen.
It's kind of like a game of hot potato
where we're just waiting
to see what coal company
is going to be left with the mine
when they eventually run out of money
and can no longer find
another coal company
to take them on.
Alpha Natural Resources
announced the transfer
of some mostly idled mining properties
in West Virginia, Kentucky, and Tennessee
to a company called
Lexington Coal Company.
Almost all the big coal
companies in the U.S.
have used a similar playbook.
The big mining companies, like Alpha,
transferred a lot of their
permits to smaller companies,
companies like Lexington,
Blackjewel, Pristine.
And then those smaller companies
have often racked up a really large number
of environmental violations.
So when Alpha and Lexington
announced the big transfer,
they said that they could
accelerate reclamation
on a five-year timeline.
Five years have passed and
not a lot has been done.
Out of about 230 permits,
only 40 have been cleaned up.
All righty, here we go.
So when I was a senior in high school,
I went to work for Massey Coal Company,
'cause I realized that
you kind of need money
to go to college in this country,
and I didn't have money
and neither did my family.
So I went to work with my dad
at the Elk Run coal processing plant.
I was just doing general maintenance.
Some days it wasn't so bad,
they just have me like cutting grass.
But some days, I'd be
waist deep in coal slurry
with a high-powered pressure hose.
I felt like I was taking
my life into my own hands
every time I'd come to work.
So I quit that job, and
by the time I was 19,
a friend of the family
offered me a position
as a security guard on a
mountaintop removal site.
But within the first week
of me working up there,
watching that machinery
tear down that mountain
for 12 hours a day made me feel
like that money I was putting in my wallet
was blood money, because it was.
I mean, the things I went
through when I was a kid
of coal trucks rumbling by your house
all hours of the night, coal trains,
you know, dust, bad water, all that,
I knew that the people who were living
down below that mine site
that I was working on
were going through the same things.
This is the underground coal mine
near my parents' house in Eunice.
You can just see coal pouring
right off the belt line
into the coal pile.
You can see an excavator
loading up a coal truck.
When I was a real young kid,
we had well water at this place,
and Massey Energy, at the time,
started getting rid of their
coal slurry by pumping it
into an old abandoned
underground coal mine
on this same hillside
that this new coal mine is now in.
That ended up making its
way through the groundwater,
through the aquifer, and
getting into our well.
And our well water at that
house was red for years
and smelled absolutely disgusting.
Yeah, this crap over here
pretty much ruined my childhood home,
so that's great.
In these underground deposits,
West Virginia has coal enough
to last the nation for generations.
Coal really powered the U.S.
Coal was used to forge weapons
during the Revolutionary War.
But for most of the first 200 years
coal was mined in the U.S.,
there were no real regulations or laws
that would make companies
clean up the land
after they were finished mining.
That changed in 1977 with
the Surface Mining Control
and Reclamation Act, SMCRA.
I recommend a three-phase program
at the federal level.
One is a law that says industry
cannot strip mine land
unless it can restore it
to its original utility
and natural purpose.
So the federal surface mining law
spells out certain requirements
about returning the land
to its approximate original contour,
so that means putting some
of that excess dirt and rock back,
kind of building the mountain back up.
They would have to re-vegetate the site
or add whatever
infrastructure might be needed
for post-mining land use.
So in a lot of cases, it
would be replanting forests,
but it could also be
building infrastructure.
They also have to address water problems.
During mining, they
control their water runoff
with sediment ponds
so that they're not letting polluted water
leave the mines.
But during reclamation, they are required
to get that mine back to the state
where it's no longer
producing polluted water.
Most companies would claim
that they're doing good reclamation
and they're doing it
as quickly as they can.
But from what we've seen on the ground,
we see mines that sit unreclaimed
for close to a decade.
So those mines aren't being reclaimed
and they are not producing coal.
They're just sitting idled.
And as they sit, they
create more pollution
and have more erosion
issues and other problems
because they're not being maintained.
Eastern Kentucky is the epicenter tonight
of the nation's latest
extreme weather disaster.
The death toll in Kentucky
continues to rise following
what the governor called,
quote, "the worst flooding
disaster he has ever seen."
There are hundreds of
unaccounted-for people, minimum.
The flooding that we've seen
in Central Appalachia in recent years
as weather events get more extreme,
that flooding has been exacerbated
by the presence of these
unreclaimed surface mines,
because the mines that
haven't been re-vegetated,
they can't hold water
like a natural forest can.
One of the greatest sources of frustration
is that, while there are laws on the books
that actually require the coal companies
to do remediation and to clean up
some of the damage that this process does,
those laws are rarely enforced.
And there millions and
millions of dollars in fines
that have been levied
against these coal companies
that they haven't paid.
So the sad truth is
that the cost of this damage is borne
by the people who live in these areas.
It was a really difficult story to report.
Some of the challenges
were people in the region.
People in West Virginia and Kentucky
were often pretty reluctant to speak
about what they'd been through
or how their homes had been damaged.
Coal provides many of the jobs,
or at least it has
historically in the region.
So people felt like they'd be speaking out
against their uncle or cousin or dad
who worked at a coal mine,
or they'd be getting dirty looks
at a grocery store.
But I think one moment
when it felt like the story
really clicked into place
is when I talked to a
man named Miles Hatfield.
He lives in Eastern Kentucky.
He lives sort of downstream or downhill
from an old Alpha mine called Love Branch.
And the mine was transferred to Lexington
as part of the big, as part
of the big asset transfer.
And he complained, even
before the transfer,
that there was flooding onto his land.
It had made his yard
into sort of a red marsh.
But the transfer to
Lexington went through,
and just as Alpha had
not cleaned up the land
or stopped the flooding of his home,
Lexington didn't stop it either
and he ended up having to move.
To me, that was a perfect example
of a mine that had been owned by Alpha
and transferred to Lexington
and not cleaned up by anyone
and then was hurting someone
that lived right next to it.
At that time, I think it was named Alpha,
but they switch back and forth.
To my understanding, they jump in and out
of bankruptcy a lot to avoid some things.
The water started coming through
probably within a year
after they quit mining.
My dining room kitchen fell in.
There wasn't no warning when it fell.
In a bat of an eye, I was
in four foot of water,
which I didn't know was
there until I went in it.
It took me about 20 minutes
to get out of the hole that I was in,
and I went upstairs and told my wife.
She couldn't believe it.
She come down and where
we did have a kitchen
and dining room, we
didn't have it anymore.
When that floor fell, that
took all the water lines out.
So we didn't have water.
We couldn't really live down here,
so we got lucky and got to rent a house
about a mile down the road there.
But there's nothing to do up here.
I keep the grass cut, and that's about it.
I would appreciate if they would step in
and take care of what damage they did.
They can't deny it,
because the scientists,
they were here three different times,
but they did say this
was from that coal mine.
They said it was their water
that's done this damage.
Not all coal companies are that bad,
it's just some of them
get the coal and get out.
The problem with SMCRA at this point
is that the requirements
for reclamation are unclear
and there isn't enough money available
to do the reclamation.
It's $11.3 billion that
taxpayers are paying
for coal companies that
went out of business
and did not leave money around
for the cleanup of what they left behind.
It's really easy for coal companies
to convince state regulators
to give them a lot of leeway
for how long it takes
them to do reclamation.
The DEP, Department of
Environmental Protection
here in West Virginia,
is a state agency, and as such,
they're ran by the state government.
Well, who in this state
runs the state government?
It's the coal industry.
And so, in that way, the coal industry
is much like a a self-regulating entity.
So we're going up Kayford
Mountain Mountain right now.
Really, Kayford is a perfect example
to show folks of how
reclamation is a farce,
because there's no way you can build back
one of the most biologically
diverse ecosystems
on the entire planet with bulldozers
and the same hydro seed you see
on the sides of interstates.
Hydro seed, it's a grass
seed mixed with fertilizer,
and like chopped up
newspaper, essentially.
But that stuff will grow
on literally anything.
You could spray that on my desk
and it it'd be ready to cut
with a lawnmower next week.
This is all the reclamation
or remediation work
that they're even liable for.
So it looks pretty awful, if you ask me.
The way the laws are structured,
if you dig ginseng before
the 1st of September,
that's federal time.
That's big, big trouble
because it's a rare
plant, it's endangered.
But these coal companies, all year round,
can blow off the tops of these mountains,
some of the most lush, dense forests
I've ever seen in my life, you know,
some of the most prime ginseng habitat
in the entire planet
just totally turned into
what amounts to a parking lot.
The mountain may not
be able to be put back
exactly like it once was,
but people can do good reclamation.
And good reclamation is
unquestionably better
than no reclamation.
So we would like to see
good reclamation done
at all of these mines.
A lot of these mines can
become productive forest again.
But it takes effort and
time and money to do that,
and a lot of the coal companies
want to avoid putting that much effort in.
I think that it is very likely
there will need to be federal funding
to cover at least some
of the reclamation that needs to be done.
Most people feel like
coal is on a decline.
We're shutting down
coal plants in the U.S.
The idea is that we'll be
using less and less coal
since it's such a dirty fossil fuel.
That said, we're in an
energy crisis right now
and there's a lot of coal being mined.
A lot of these companies
are seeing record profits.
Alpha, for example, is doing great.
Its stock is up over 700%
from when it left bankruptcy.